اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا
المساء ملفين ونبدا بالعناوين
بالاستئناف مشاركه وفد الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه في اجتماعات مجلس جامعه الدول
العربيه وجميع
بعد اكثر من عقد سوريا تعود للجامعه
العربيه خطوه مقابله خطوه هل اقتربت
الازمه السوريه من نهايتها ام لا تزال
بعيده عن ذلك
وفي ملفنا الثاني بعد 20 عاما من الحكم
انتخابات صعبه تنتظر اردوغان فهل سيمنحه
ارثه الفوز ام تحقق المعارضه احلامها
وتعطي شبابه تركيا قائدا جديدا
ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى نقاش ملفنا الاول
بعد غياب 12 عاما تعود سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه بمنهجيه خطوه مقابله خطوه
ففي اجتماع استثنائي عقده مجلس الجامعه
العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه في
القاهره تقررت استعاده سوريا عضويتها
واستئناف مشاركتها في اجتماعات مجلس جامع
اعتبارا من السابع من مايو وتشكيل لجنه
لمتابعه تنفيذ بيان عمان والاستمرار
بالحوار المباشر مع دمشق ملفه عوده سوريا
الى جامعه الدول العربيه لم يخضع للتصويت
بل اتخذ بالتوافق وزير الخارجيه المصريه
سامح شكري طالب الحكومه السوريه والمكونات
السياسيه العمل على حل سياسي مستقر في
البلاد كما طالب الحكومه السوريه العمل
على اعاده اللاجئين السوريين من الخارج
مؤكدا ان الجميع يتطلع الى طي صفحه سوريا
الحزينه كما قال وجاء القرار عقب بحث
نتائج الاجتماعات الوزاريه العربيه
المصغره التي عقدت في السعوديه والاردن
لبحث عوده سوريا الى الجامعه ودعوتها الى
القمه العربيه المقبله في الرياضه
لان السبيل الوحيد للتسويه هو الحل
السياسي بملكيه سوريه خالصه دون املاءات
خارجيه
واستيفاء الاجراءات المرتبطه بتحقيق
التوافق الوطني بين الاشقاء السوريين
وبناء الثقه ومواصله اجتماعات اللجنه
الدستوريه على نحو يتمشى مع المرجعيات
الدوليه وقرار مجلس الامن رقم 22 54
وبما يلبي تطلعات الشعب السوري ويحقق
اماله المشروع في غد افضل
ويضمن الحفاظ على وحده
سوريا وسيادتها وسلامتها الاقليميه
وعروباتها وينهي كل مظاهر التدخلات
الخارجيه في شؤونها بما في ذلك الاعتداءات
على اراضيها
هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره السفير
حمدي صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه سابقا اهلا
بك من عمان استاذ العلاقات الدوليه وفض
النزاعات في الجامعه الاردنيه الدكتور حسن
المومني اهلا بك ومن دمشق عبر سكايب عبد
الحميد توفيق الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام في الواقع للبدء بفهم هذا
الملف وحضراتكم تعلمون بانه منذ البدء
بالحديث عن هذا القرار كانت هناك مواقف
عديده بين رافض وبين مساند لهكذا قرار
وكان هناك خاصه مفاهيم او بعض العناوين
التي قراناها ومن بينها عوده سوريا مثلا
للحضن العربي وهنا اسال حضرتك سفير حمدي
صالح هل هذا القرار يعني بالاساس عوده
سوريا الى الحضن العربي بمعنى تطبيع
العلاقات السوريه العربيه
وراب الخلافات تماما بين مجموعه من الدول
العربيه والسوريه تعتقد
يعني كما اشار امين عامل الجامعه العربيه
السفير احمد ابو الغيط فان التطبير
العلاقات بين الدول العربيه والسوريه قرر
كل دوله على حدهم ولكن ما هو مهم في هذا
ان هذا التطور بالغ الاهميه ليس فقط
لسوريا بل للنظام الاقليمي العربي يعني
احنا عندنا مشكله حقيقيه في النظام
الاقليمي منذ خروج سوريا منذ هذه الفتره
من 2011
حصل تدهور خطير في نظام الاقليم العربي
وبالتالي عندما تعود الحركه والنشاط الى
التجمع العربي بان يكون هناك لقاءات في
السعوديه ثم في عمان لمناقشه القضيه
السوريه ثم اتخذها الموقف لعوده السوريه
لهذا يعني ان هناك تحرك حقيقي في النظام
الاقليمي لاعاده التوازن وامكانيه ان تحل
المجموعه العربيه قضاياها بنفسها فده تطور
مهم حصل تدهور خطير في عشر سنين اللي فاتت
عندما تدخلت القوه الاجنبيه
الاقليميه والقوه الدوليه في في المنطقه
وحصلت تطور خطير ايضا في انتشار الارهاب
ومائليه بل ايضا حصل تدهور في الامن
الاقليمي ليس فقط على المستوى الواسع وهو
العلاقات بين الدول ولكن على مستوى الضيق
انتشار الجريمه المنظمه والمخدرات
وبالتالي عندما تعود المجموعه العربيه
لمناقشه هذا واتخاذ موقف موحد لاعاده
العلاقه بين سوريا والدول العربيه هذا
يعني تطور مهم جدا للنظام الاقليمي ككل
وليس فقط لسوريا وهنا اؤكد على ان القضيه
ليست فقط عوده الى مبنى الجامعه العربيه
والنهي عوده للتفاعل الفعال ما بين الدول
العربيه بشكل بكل اشكالها وسوريا وده بدا
منذ فتره يعني بدا هناك بلقاءات متعدده
بين وزراء الخارجيه العرب وعدد وزير
الوزراء الخارجيه العرب وسوريا وبالتالي
هذه البدايه تحرك الحقيقي صحيح حضرتك تقول
بانها بدايه تفاعل وهذا الاطار في الواقع
الذي تحدث عنه
امين عام الجامعه العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
ونحن سنتابع تصريح له لنضع كذلك النقاط
على الحروف لنفهم هذا التطور ولنوضح
المفاهيم والمصطلحات والمفردات كذلك التي
تم استخدامها احمد ابو الغيط يقول مثلا
بان عوده سوريا لشغل المقعد هو بدايه حركه
وليس نهايه مطاف سنذهب لمتابعه هذا
هذه التصريحات ونعود من جديد لمناقشه هذه
التطورات
عوده سوريا الى شغل المقعد
هي بدايه حركه وليست نهايه مطاف بمعنى انه
مسار التسويه للازمه السوريه هتاخذ مرحله
من الاجراءات والتدرج فيها ومهمه هذه
اللجنه هي متابعه هذه
الاجراءات ايضا هي ليس
بقرار
لاقامه علاقات طبيعيه بين الدول العربيه
وسوريا هذا قرار سياجي لكل دوله على حده
نحن نتحدث في هذا القرار عن
شغل المقعد وتشكيل اللجنه للتواصل مع
الحكم في سوريا طيب وهذه النقطه واضحه
احمد ابو الغيط قال بانه عوده سوريا لشغله
مقعدها هو
موقف مع الجامعه العربيه ولا يلزم الدول
بتطبيع العلاقات معها ولكن قال كذلك دكتور
حسن شيء اخر هو يقول عوده سوريا ليشغل
المقعد هو بدايه حركه وليست نهايه وطاف
اود ان اتوقف معك عند هذا التوصيف لانه
غايه في الاهميه البعض قرا عوده سوريا
لشغل المقعد بانه كانها نتيجه احمد ابو
الغيط يقول هذه البدايه ولكن نهايه المطاف
شيء اخر ومن هنا لهناك يجب تفعيل مجموعه
من الاجراءات حضرتك هل ترى بان هذه
الاجراءات قادره ان تفعل بحضن عربي عربي
مساء الخير
الكرام والمشاهدين مما لا شك فيه ما جرى
عبر الاسابيع الماضيه والذي توج في اجتماع
جده ثم بعد ذلك عمان والدبلوماسيه
التشاوري واليوم حقيقه توج في اجتماع
وزاره الخارجيه هي محاوله خلق مسار سياسي
عمليه سياسيه
قطعا ستاخذ وقت وجهد وتطلب حوار
ومساومه ومفاوضات واتخاذ اجراءات بهذا
الجانب فلذلك اذا بدي انا اعطيها توصيف
ومسار بفاعليه عربيه بدور عربي رئيسي كنا
قد شهدنا في المساله السوريه مسارات
متعدده كان هنالك جنيفه كان هنالك استانا
كان كل هذا الجانب الان الجديد حقيقه ان
المسار العربي قد يكون هنالك ظروف مواتيه
اكثر فرصه جاذبه اكثر لذلك نرى هذه
النجاحات الجزئيه التراكميه التي عليها
قرار عوده سوريا الى جامعه الدول العربيه
وهنا دعني اوضح عوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه هي ليست الغايه وانما وسيله
لتساهم في خلق مسار واشتباك سوري عربي
لخلق عمليه سياسيه بهذا الجانب وبالتالي
ايضا يتبعوا اشتباك في الجانب الاقليمي
والجانب الدولي لانه هنا نتحدث شغله على
المساله السوريه مساله معقده بقضايا معقده
تتطلب جهد بهذا الجانب اما اني انا اختزل
بان عوده سوريا وانتهت كل هذه الامور لا
قطعا ما زالت القضايا الخلافيه موجوده
المتعلقه داخل البيت السوري والمتعلقه
ايضا في مساله سوريا ودول الجوار وغيرها
في هذا الجانب فلذلك هنا نتحدث عن مسار
وقد نسميه ما شئنا مسار جنيه مسار جده
مسار عمان مسار جامعه الدول العربيه زيه
زي مسار الستانه لكن حقيقه الشيء المختلف
ان الان الظروف الاقليميه والى حد ما
الدوليه ومساله ايضا ظروف انسانيه الزلزال
وغيره خلق ما يسمى في علم اداره النزاعات
فرصه جاذبه تم تطويرها من قبل الدول
الوازنه العربيه بمجلس التعاون الخليجي
مصر العراق والاردن حقيقه
في الدبلوماسيه التشاوريه وهذا نمط ايضا
ومنهجيه اثبتت نجاحها في الدبلوماسيه
العربيه في هذا الجانب لذلك هو بدايه مسار
اسس لقاعده انطلاق وما زال هنالك حقيقه
شوط طويل ومفاوضات طويله وانت تعلمي
وضيوفك يعلم بان المفاوضات قد تكون صعبه
حتى بين الاصدقاء مبالغ في وضع معقد زي
المساله السوريه اللي
مستويات مختلفه في هذا الامر صحيح
وهناك تعقيدات وهناك
اطراف اقليميه ودوليه كذلك معنيه بكل هذه
التطورات ولكن استاذ عبد الحميد ان يكون
منطلق التاسيس لهكذا تقارب هو منهجيه
الخطوه مقابل خطوه الدول العربيه تقدمت
بالخطوه الاولى ورحبت بسوريا ومكانتها من
العوده ل منصبها ما المنتظر من الجانب
السوري
مساء الخير اهلا بك
الخارطه التي رسمت عناوينها الاساسيه في
جده ومن ثم في عمان والتاكيد عليها وايضا
تكررت على مدار الساعات الماضيه قبل
الاعلان عرض السوريه واضحه وصريحه من
الجانب العربي او من الرباعيه العربيه
باتجاه سوريا وهي حقيقه تعني مدخلا اساسيا
لمقاربه جديده للوضع السوري ومحاوله حل
الازمه خطوه مقابل خطوه يعني ان العرب حين
تقدموا هذه الخطوه كان من جانب سوريا خطوه
اخرى وهي بدايه كانت التفاعل مع كل هذه
الطروحات ولو لم يكن هناك اجوبه واضحه
اجوبه واضحه من الجانب السوري باتجاه
خارطه العمل العربي اعتقد انها تطورت الى
هذه الحاله الخطوات
السؤال المطروح لو سمحت هل يمكن لسوريا ان
تتفاعل دون تاثيرات خارج يه ان تتفاعل مع
المجموعه العربيه دون تاثيرات دوليه دون
تاثيرات خارجيه هل هذا يمكن
انا اعتقد بان هذه المساله اليوم باتت
ممكنه اكثر مما كانت عليه في السابق
لثلاثه عوامل اولا هو العامل العربي
استطيع ان اسمي ما حدث لسوريا في بين
بالرباعيه العربيه وعند العرب بانه اشبه
بمشروع مارشال عربي لسوريا لان مقوماته
تقوم على الاقتصاد والامن والسياسه
والسياده والاستقلال فاعتقد انا استطيع ان
ارمي هذه الجمله تسميه على ما قام به
العرب بالتالي اليوم التقدم العربي خطوه
مهمه جدا باتجاه سوريا كسر اسوار الازمه
السوريه العنيده وتشعباتها الداخليه
والاقليميه والعربيه مهمه نقطه مهمه تسمح
لسوريا بتقدير ان تجعل التفاعل مع الجانب
العربي اكثر لماذا لان اليوم الاتراك
يتوجهون الى سوريا وموجوده ايران وموجود
روسيا ولهم مصالح في هذا الامر اليوم
العرب السعوديه وايران تبني علاقه جديده
واتفاقيه برعايه دوله كالصين وهذه العناصر
المشتركه باتت قادره على اعطاء سوريا
ملامح اساسيه للتصرف باتجاه البيت العربي
بطريقه غير ما كانت عليه في السابق بعد ان
تم هدم هذا الجدار بين سوريا وبين العالم
العربي وازيل هذا الجانب النفسي والسياسي
ايضا واستطيع القول بان التجاوب السوري
سيتفاعل اكثر باكثر مما هو عليه حتى اليوم
من هذه
الاسباب داخليه والاقليميه والعربيه اولا
سفير حمدي اليوم يقول الباص تعليقا على
هذا التطور بان الكره باتت في مرمى او في
ملعب السوريين في ملعب النظام السوري في
ملعب بشار الاسد بتحديد حتى نسمي الامور
بمسمياتها هل تتفق مع ضيف الاستاذ عبد
الحميد بانه الخطوه الاولى قدمها العرب
الخطوه الثانيه قدمتها سوريا بالتفاعل ام
ان التفاعل لا يكفي يجب ان تكون هناك
اجراءات محدده لبناء ثقه بين الطرفين وما
الاجراء الاول الذي يجب ان تعتمده سوريا
لو بالتاكيد هذا التفاعل يجب ان ياتي من
الطرفين من الطرف العربي ومن الطرف السوري
وما حدث حتى الان ان الجامعه العربيه
اتخذت قرارا بعوده سوريا
لوجود للتمثيل لوجود تمثيلها في الجامعه
العربيه بكل وكالاتها مش بس
المكان
المندوبين السياسيين ولكن سيترتب على هذا
ايضا ان يكون هناك لجنه تشاوريه تحدث عنها
السفير احمد ابو الغيط بانه سيكون هناك
لجنه وتشاوريه
من مجموعه من الدول العربيه وبالاضافه الى
الامين العام تتشاور مع الجانب السوري
لتحقيق الخطوات اللازمه لحل الازمه
السوريه الداخليه والازمه السوريه
المرتبطه بالعالم العربي النقطه الاساسيه
في هذا ان هذه الازمه في الواقع لها بعدين
هي بعد داخلي سوري وبعد دولي اقليمي ودولي
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تتحرك الامور الا بان
يحل تحل هذه القضايا المتراكمه الداخليه
والخارجيه الداخليه مرتبطه بالتوازنات
السياسيه الداخليه وتحدث وزير الخارجيه
المصري باعتبار رئيس الاجتماعي الحالي على
انه يجب ان يكون هناك توافق بين المكونات
السياسيه المختلفه في سوريا والحكومه
السوريه وان يكون هناك مسار سياسي يسمح
بتحريك الامور وايضا عوده اللاجئين وما
الى قضايا متعدده تحدثت عنها
الاجتماعات التشاوريه في جده وفي عمان
وهذه القضايا بالمؤكد ان سوريا قدمت يعني
اشاره ايجابيه بانها ستعمل بشكل ايجابي
معها ولكن القضيه النقطه الثانيه المهمه
هي الموقف الدولي والموقف الاقليمي عندما
يتحدث زميلنا من السوريه على انه هناك
تغير في الموقف التركي او متغير في الموقف
الايراني نحن ايضا نتحدث على انه يجب ان
يكون هناك تقويه للموقف السوري في محاوله
ايجاد الصيغه استقلاليه كامله لسوريا عن
القوى الاقليميه التي تدخلت في سوريا سواء
كانت من الاقليميه او حتى من القوه
الدوليه ومن ضمنها روسيا وبالتالي
يعني هذا تغيير في الموقف التفاوضي السوري
في حقل الرد كذلك استاذ عبد الحميد ضيف
يقول بانه يجب على سوريا ان تكون مستقله
تماما حتى تبني هذه العلاقات بطريقه يمكن
ان تكون
وثيقه بين هذه الاطراف سوريا اليوم ليست
مستقله تماما
فكيف يمكن العمل على هذا الملف مثلا
صحيح وهذا الكلام الذي تفضل به الضيف
الكريم دقيق جدا الاستقلاليه الرؤيه
السوريه استقلاليه القرار السوري ايضا لا
بد منه كي يتخذ القرارات التي تطمئن
الجانب العربي وتنزع كل هواجسه من خلال
دفع هذه التبعات التدخل الاقليمي في سوريا
سواء كانت المرغمه عليه كما حدث من جانب
تركيا في سوريا او تلك التي تعيش معها او
تقوم تقيم معها علاقات لا طابع استراتيجي
بين سوريا وايران الى العاملين
الاقليميين الروسي عفوا التركي والايراني
هذا تصور بان
التجاوب العربي والتفاعل بين سوريا والعرب
في هذه الخطوات يمكن ان يمنح سوريا هذا
الهامش لكي تكون قادره على التعامل مع
الجانب التركي في التفاوض بانهاء الوجود
التركي والهاء كل التعقيدات التي سببها
الوجود التركي وتبعاته وكذلك لتكون قادره
على التعامل مع ايران على قاعده توازن
المصالح ان تكون مصالح سوريه مع ايران
متوازنه ولا تؤدي الى اي اثاره اي هواجس
لدى الجانب العربي وان تكون ايضا الدوره
الايراني في سوريا دور ايجابي غير مقلق
للجانب العربي لا بمحيط سوريا ولا خارج
محيط سوريا طيب تحدثنا منذ قليل في معرض
كلامنا دكتور حسن عن الخلافات السوريه
السوريه وقد تكون كذلك هذه النقطه نقطه
يعني تركيز من جميع الاطراف لان الموضوع
متشعب
في حساسيات وتعقيدات اليوم المعارضه
السوريه
اعلن بانها ترفض مثل هكذا قرار اولا هي
تعتمد فقط على القرارات الامميه هي تعتمد
للعوده على القرار الاممي 22- وبالتالي
كيف يمكن حل هكذا خلاف خاصه وان للمعارضه
قاعده في داخل السوري وان النظام السوري
بحسب الاحصائيات لا يسيطر الا على
هناك اربعين بالمئه من الاراضي السوريه لا
يسيطر عليها بحسب ما يقال طبعا فكيف يمكن
حل هذه النقطه دكتور
يعني هم لا شك فيه الحاله يعني متجدره
حاله خلافيه ما بين القوى الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه المعارضه
وايضا النظام في سوريا بهذا الجانب وانتم
الكل يذكر انه اصلا كانت مساله تصنيف من
هو المعارضه الذي نستطيع ان نتحدث منه ومن
هي المعارضه الذي لا نستطيع ان نتحدث ضحى
في هذا الجانب الان في وضع مثالي انا
بتقدير الشخصي جمع كل القوى المعارضه في
سياق واحد ودعنا نتحدث عن المعارضه وكان
كيان واحد بهذا الجانب بهذا الاتجاه ممكن
هنا نتحدث عن
غالبيه القوى المعارضه اللي قد
توافق على مثلا خارطه الطريق التي تم
تبنيها من الجانب العربي بهذا الجانب
وتنخرط مع النظام في مساله الحوار ومساله
التفاوض والمشاكل قطعا تحل من خلال الحوار
ومغادره ما يسمى في مربع صفريه
وقوى المعارضه
ولكن دكتور حسن هل
اللجنه التي يعني يمكن ان نقول بانه
الجامعه العربيه تحدثت عنها وهي التي
ستؤسس
للالتزام بهذه الاجراءات هل هذه اللجنه
لديها
ربما اتصالات مع المعارضه
يعني هو كثير من الدول العربيه لها
اتصالات مع المعارضه لا تنسي المنصات
السابقه اللي كانت موجوده وهذه الدول الى
الان وافقت على عوده سوريا وافقت على
العمليه السياسيه ووافقت على تاسيس هذا
المسار بامكان التاثير حقيقه بهذا الجانب
وبهذا الاتجاه تركيا نفسها حتى يعني بدات
الاستداره قبل الحديث عن مساله المبادره
العربيه تركيا نفسها اشتبكت مع سوريا ايش
تبقت مع ايران واشتبكت مع روسيا في مساله
المباحثات ومساله اعاده التعيير لكثير من
القضايا بهذا الجانب لذلك احنا نتحدث عن
عمليه طويله لذلك نتحدث عن عمليه طويله في
هذا الجانب بهذا الاتجاه فلذلك بتقدير
الشخصي مساله وقطعا هذه قضايا شائكه لذلك
مثلا في بيان عمان جرى الحديث عن مساله
اللجنه الدستوريه جرى الحديث عن 22 54 في
هذا الامر
وبنهايه المطاف لو انها كان هنالك توافق
دكتور لو انها كان هنالك بين النظام وبين
لما كان في داعي للمفاوضات ولكنك لما تقول
بان اللجنه المعنيه بمتابعه هذا الموضوع
في الاردن
طرحت موضوع اولا القرار الاممي سنه 20 54
وكذلك طرحت مختلف الاجتماعات هل نفهم بانه
ما سيتم الاتفاق عنه سيبنى على استانا على
هذه القرارات الامميه او سيكون منفصل
تماما عنها ما موقف المعارضه في هذا مثلا
عمليه سياسيه بالمناسبه وقد الاطراف تخلق
مرجعيات وتطور ما اتفق عليه
في في جنيفه بهذا الجانب هلا قد نستفيد من
هذه الموازات لكن انت تعلمي ان المفاوضات
عمليه سياسيه يحدد ديناميكيتها ونتائجها
الاطراف بهذا الامر وقد وقد نرى مخرجات
ممكن اما تتوافق على ما اتفق عليه سابقا
او ما تتعارض لانه في نهايه المطاف احنا
بهمنا الان نتحدث عن عمليه سياسيه تنتج
توافق بهذا الجانب
و54 يمكن بتفسيرات كثيره
اسمح لي فقط الوقت ان انقل هذه النقطه
واعذرني على المقاطعه ساعود لك سفير حمزه
ولكن بما يخص نقطه المعارضه انقلها لك
استاذ عبد الحميد والاكيد بانك اقرب لنا
اقرب منا كلنا للمشهد السوري وبالتالي ما
موقف المعارضه من كل هذا لاننا لا نتحدث
عن نظام فقط نحن نتحدث عن شقين وهناك هو
كبيره بينهما دامت اكثر من عشر سنوات
نعم اعتقد بانه تسميه اجنحه المعارضه
السوريه بالمنصات تسميه لها مدلولات وهناك
منصه في مصر وهناك منصه في روسيا وهناك
المنصه الرئيسيه في تركيا بكل اطياف
المعارضه سواء السياسيه او المسلحه بما
فيها جبهه النصره ذراع تنظيم القاعده
الارهابي في بلاد الشام اعتقد بان
المعارضه اليوم لا تملك من امرها في هذا
الموضوع سوى ان تتجانس مع الطروحات
العربيه لماذا لان الجانب المصري بدا
تواصله مع
رئيس اللجنه او رئيس اللجنه المفاوضات
للجنه الدستوريه
من منذ يومين تحدث اليه في هذا الاطار
وبالتالي المواقف
عبد الحميد وان قررت ان لا تتجانس مع هذا
القرار مثلا وهي تملك بيدها قاعده شعبيه
وتملك بيدها كما تعلم حضرتك عد دا كبيرا
من السوريين في الداخل وفي الخارج كذلك
التي يمكن طرحها وقتها
انا اعتقد بان
العلاقه السوريه التركيه التي تبدو انها
قيد الانقاذ لاعاده التطبيع برعايه
الروسيه ودورايراني واليوم الدوره العربي
في هذا الاطار بوجود منصه في القاهره يمكن
ان تبلور خطوط وقواسم مشتركه في هذا
التوجه وكذلك لا انسى دور المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي ايضا رات بعض المنصات
للمعارضه ويمكن لها ان تؤثر كامله على في
بالاتجاهين سواء على الحكومه السوريه وعلى
نظام السوري او على المعارضه للوصول الى
كلمه سواء ولكن اعتقد بان هذه المساله
ستكون بعد مراحل ليس في المدى المنظور لان
هناك اولويات وضعت في الخارطه العربيه
لسوريا الاولويه الولائيه للجانب الانساني
والاولويه الثانيه الجانب الامني
والاولويه الثالثه هي للجانب السياسي ولكن
ربما كلها هذه
المنصات الموجوده بتاثير الرعاه لها يمكن
ايضا بالتفاهم مع الجانب السوري ان تنت
قواسم مشتركه يمكن ان تصل الى كلمه سواء
في اطار سياسي لان المساله الداخليه
السوريه تم تصنيفها بشكل واضح من قبل وزير
الخارجيه البصري بانها ستكون سوريه سوريه
كامله سفير حمزه حضرتك تعلم بانه مع هكذا
تطور كانت هناك اختلافات عديده في تقبل او
في رفض هذا القرار ولكن سؤال مطروح من
انتصر مع عوده سوريا وشغله منصبها
وكرسيها في جامعه الدول العربيه هل انتصر
بشر الاسد هل انتصار نظامه
هل استسلمت المعارضه ام هي السياسه وهكذا
يجب ان تقاد
يعني هي دي الحقيقه دي مشكله عميقه لان
المجتمع السوري انقسم انقساما بالغ
الخطوره وكانت هناك دماء وسيله وبالتالي
هذه القضايا التي على مر عشر سنين لا يمكن
ان تحلل في يعني في فتره قصيره او زي ما
اشروا زميلنا من سوريا ستاخذ وقت ولكن
القضايا المحوريه الان انه قد تغير الموقف
الاقليمي وتطوير الموقف الدولي تغير
الموقف الاقليمي ان هناك الان اهتمام بالغ
ان يكون هناك تحرك نحو المسار السياسي
واحنا التوافق بين هذه المكونات
وحل هذه المشاكل وبالتالي اذا كان هذا
انتصار فهو انتصار للشعب السوري وليس
انتصار
الرئيس بشار الاسد او المعارضه هو انتشار
الانتصار للشعب السوري اشير الى نقطه مهمه
جدا وهي تحول الموقف الامريكي الموقف
الامريكي كان معارضا معارضه مباشره دلوقتي
بيتحدثوا عن انهم سيتابعون المقاربه
الامريكيه ستتابع المسار السياسي هذا
الموقف يمثل تحول الوقف الدولي ككل
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومائه وبالتالي عندما
يكون هناك يعني مناخ اقليمي ومناخ دولي
مساعد على تحريك المكونات السياسيه
الداخليه للتوافق وايضا على تحريك
العلاقات ما بين السوريه والدول المجاوره
بشكل ايجابي ستتغير الموقف وبالتالي انا
اعتقد ان هناك يعني نظره تفاؤليه بامكانيه
التحرك نحو الامام سوريا دوله مهمه جدا
لنا في مصر وفي المنطقه العربيه ككل
وستلعب دورا هاما في المنطقه المستقبل
القريب وهي احدى الدول المؤسسه لجامعه
الدول العربيه كذلك اود شكركم جزيل الشكر
على كل ما تفضلتم به من القاهره
سفير حمزه صالح مساعد وزير الخارجيه
المصريه سابقا من عمان استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه وفرض النزاعات في الجامعه
الاردنيه دكتور حسن
عبد الحميد توفيق الكاتبه الصحفي شكرا لكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات